mon administration défend également fermement
notre sécurité nationale et
combat le terrorisme islamique radical la
semaine dernière, j'ai annoncé un plan révolutionnaire
pour la paix entre Israël et les
Palestiniens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est temps de reconnaître officiellement
Jérusalem comme capitale  d'Israël dont
le centre commercial officiel Audrey musujime n'est pas
ambasada américain Asura heureux ou C
et je peux fournir la jambe la plus longue
[Musique]
dans un instant je signerai une
proclamation présidentielle reconnaissant la souveraineté d'Israël
sur les hauteurs du Golan l'
État d'Israël a pris le contrôle des
hauteurs du Golan  en 1967 pour protéger la
sécurité des menaces extérieures, les
États-Unis restent profondément déterminés
à aider à faciliter la paix et je
ferai tout ce que je peux pour aider cette cause.
L'accord d'aujourd'hui est une
occasion historique pour les Palestiniens de
parvenir enfin à
leur propre État indépendant après 70  années de peu de
progrès, cela pourrait être la dernière
occasion qu'ils auront
de b  e coruña capable et la rulinea una
una une autre Marvel pour être une
autre personne métallurgique et
[Musique]
vous